hey spo you you mentioned their
physicality after game one obviously
without bam
it seemed like the lakers again their
size and physicality was a factor
especially on the glass how big of a
impact you think that was
well yeah i mean it clearly was
in those moments of truth uh when we had
opportunities uh
you know to to get the game closer it
usually seemed to end up in some kind of
offensive rebound or something
uh near the basket but this is the deal
and if you want something badly enough
you'll figure out how
to overcome it they have a great size
and anthony davis is
um you know an elite uh player we're
trying to get something accomplished
and you just have to
you have to go to another level um
that's the bottom line i i love
a lot of things the way we competed uh
tonight but i think
another level would have put us in a
position
to have a you know an opportunity you
know real opportunity
there at the end and that's what you
want um
and that's that's part of the the
process of learning you know how to get
to that next
level so we got you know some time
tomorrow to
to review it uh on it and get better
next question tab deportes hi coach
the next game maybe will be the most
important game of the series for you
guys
what is the beast adjustment the team
need to do to win
the nets game yeah every game is the
most important game
tonight was the most important game uh
but we'll get to work tomorrow um
you know we do i need to look at the
film you know we need to get together as
a team and
and come up with a plan you know for
game three
thank you
all right next question mark schwartz
eric
two things one what does another level
look like right now with bam and goron
on the sideline and two
what is it about your group you know to
watch udonis talk to them in the third
quarter
you know you can see the passion and the
resiliency in that guy's veins
what is it about your group that can
overcome
what the world thinks is an impossible
mountain
we don't give a [ __ ] what everybody else
thinks uh
whatever um your first question how did
you phrase it
uh what will it take whatever is
necessary it's as simple as that if you
want something badly enough
you'll figure it out and our group is
extremely stubborn
persistent and we just need to figure
out
uh you know how to overcome uh this
opponent uh and that we respect
uh the quality high quality of opponent
that we're playing
you gotta figure it out and overcome it
you said after last game that you just
didn't think it was a good example of
heat basketball
tonight where does that fall on the line
between heat basketball and very far
away from here
i'm not necessarily going to grade it i
mean certainly it was a
much better competitive disposition our
guys brought it
and look if it if it
ends up being whatever it was 10 12
point game
then we need to make up 10 12 points to
overcome that you know
13 14 points to make sure we get the win
that's you know that's what
uh we'll get to work on
but look i love these guys i love the
way we compete
we have to figure out how to to overcome
this and get over over the top
tim reynolds in the back eric i know you
don't want to
i'm certainly not suggesting you go
gimmicky or anything but are you taking
enough threes do you want to get to a
place where you're even getting more of
those up especially early
uh i do need to get to the film tim but
that is a a good point
um you know when we got it to about 10
um several times during the second half
um i thought we rushed
some of those possessions we don't want
to play prevent offense by
any means but execute
a little bit more with poise and get the
exact shot that we want
and oftentimes that that shot probably
would have been
you know some kind of uh three but it
takes a little bit more
patience and poise and um
and intentionality to be able to uh
generate a few more looks yeah
i think i would have liked a few more
looks but we had you know opportunities
for feature line opportunities in the
paint
um it was just some of those rushed
opportunities when we had an opportunity
to
get that thing to 10 you know see if you
can get that to four
next question anthony chang obviously
with with goron and bam out so much foul
on jimmy's shoulders
play 45 minutes career high in assists
for the playoffs what did you think
about his performance especially
offensively i love jimmy
you know what we're all learning as a as
a group
you lay it all out there he is
a supreme competitor
you can't define him by any analytic or
or typical viewpoint
of of how to play the game of basketball
because he's going to compete and he's
going to find different ways to compete
to put yourself
your team in a position to win and
it was 45 minutes of everything he had
and career high and assists and
he's going to have to get to another
level that's
that's the deal and and he loves that
that type of challenge and
um and we have 48 hours to figure that
out
i know it's less about schematics but
after playing
zones so sparingly in game one what went
into the decision to use it so heavily
tonight was it just personnel that was
available
and knowing guys are gonna have to play
a big one of everything yeah some of its
personnel some of it
um you know
it was a different look you know for our
defense
but we didn't finish a lot of those
those plays so i don't think it really
would have mattered um
man or zone um there was you know
probably eight ten of those possessions
where we just did not finish it with
uh that next level of of commitment
um which has to this this opponent is
going to require us to go there
and the last question for coach bolster
jarrett weiss
tyler and kelly had to step into much
bigger roles tonight with the injuries
how do you feel like that went
hey they're a big part of of who we are
regardless i mean ko got obviously a lot
more minutes but
tyler has been this guy for several
weeks
so we're not we're not going back on
that now
this is who we are